bienvenidos a la presentación de las
desigualdades cuadráticas yo sé que
suena algo muy complicado pero estoy
seguro de que verán que no es tan
difícil así que vamos a empezar
resolviendo algunos ejercicios y verás
que es ligeramente distinto a resolver
desigualdades tradicionales así que
digamos que tengo la desigualdad
siguiente x cuadrada más 3 x es mayor
que 10 muy bien y es es siempre tan tan
tentador hacer lo mismo que cuando
teníamos desigualdades lineales por
ejemplo no es decir 11 cuando tenía
desigualdades lineales buscaba pasar de
un lado digamos del lado izquierdo todo
lo que tuviera una x mientras que todas
las constantes las buscábamos pasar del
lado derecho y esto esto en general no
funciona porque tenemos una x cuadrada
verdad y eso vuelve más complicada un
poquito más complicada la resolución de
este tipo de problemas pero lo que vamos
a poder hacer es llevar este esta
desigualdad a una forma
muy bien y la font de la forma estándar
digo no sé si así se le dice en todos
lados pero al menos es pasar todo lo que
tengamos en la desigualdad del lado
izquierdo muy bien entonces si nosotros
hacemos eso tendremos x cuadrada más 3x
y restamos 10 de ambos lados entonces
nos quedan menos 10 mayor que 0 y esto
es a lo que yo le voy a llamar la forma
estándar y por qué nos sirve esto pues
porque ya tenemos un polinomio de grado
2 un polinomio cuadrática que podríamos
factorizar muy bien entonces a lo mejor
ya estás muy familiarizado con la
factorización de polinomios del segundo
grado así que buscamos dos números que
multiplicados me den menos 10 y sumados
me den 3 muy bien entonces
inmediatamente podemos ver que 10 no
tiene tantos factores así que por
ejemplo 5 y menos 2 funciona en verdad 5
x menos 12 es menos diez y cinco menos
dos es tres así que esto se puede
factorizar como
x 5 x x menos 2 y esto tiene que ser
mayor que 0 y aquí viene la parte
distinta porque tenemos los números que
multiplicados nos dan algo positivo
entonces quedémonos con esta parte hagan
hagan tantito una pausa porque esta es
la parte un poquito más complicada de
todo pero te darás cuenta que no lo es
tanto
tenemos dos números cualesquiera digamos
ahí ve que al multiplicarse nos dan algo
positivo muy bien entonces piensa en dos
números que al multiplicarse sean
positivos entonces inmediatamente te
darás cuenta que pues a bueno hay ahí
hay dos casos para para para este tipo
de problemas tenemos que a es mayor que
0 y b es mayor que 0 es decir para que
una una multiplicación me dé algo
positivo pues ambos tienen que ser
positivos o también o también puede
pasar que hace a menor que cero ibex sea
menor que cero verdad es decir que ambos
sean negativos por ejemplo menos 2 x
menos 3
6 positivo verdad entonces tiene que
pasar que ambos son positivos o ambos
son negativos es decir esencialmente
podemos reducir en que ambos deben tener
el mismo signo entonces eso mismo puede
pasar con esto tenemos un producto de
dos números uno es x + 5 y el otro es x
menos 2 que es mayor que 0 así que ambos
deben tener el mismo signo es decir debe
pasar que x + 5 es mayor que 0 y x menos
dos es mayor que 0
esto es una opción o la otra
no también puede pasar que x 5 sea
negativo y x2 sea negativo que son
justamente estos dos casos que
escribimos aquí arriba entonces vamos a
ver que el resultado tenemos si x + 5 es
mayor que 0 quiere decir que x es mayor
que menos 5 y al mismo tiempo x menos 2
es mayor que 0 eso quiere decir que x es
mayor que 2
este es nuestro nuestra primera
posibilidad la otra posibilidad que
tenemos la otra posibilidad que tenemos
es que x sea menor que menos 5 y que x
sea menor que 2 muy bien entonces
cualquiera de estas dos opciones nos dan
soluciones a esta desigualdad
ahora bien pensemos que significa que x
sea mayor que menos 5 y que al mismo
tiempo sea mayor que que 2 por ejemplo
si ponemos aquí una pequeña recta
numérica y ponemos el menos 5 y el 2
entonces las x están a la derecha de
menos 5 verdad
todos estos son todos estos pero al
mismo tiempo deben estar a la derecha de
dos entonces el único conjunto que
cumple ambas condiciones es a partir del
2 todos estos y por supuesto el 2 no lo
cumple porque es un mayor estricto muy
bien entonces esa es una y la otra nos
dice bueno para para resumir este
conjunto son los x mayores que 2 muy
bien la otra posibilidad es la siguiente
tenemos de digamos otra vez de menos 5 y
2 muy bien ahí está nuestra recta y nos
dice que x debe ser menor que menos 5 es
decir todos estos que están a la
izquierda y al mismo tiempo deben ser
menores que 2 son todos los que están a
la izquierda de 2 así que el único lugar
en donde se satisfacen ambas condiciones
son todos estos que son menores que
menos 5 verdad y menos 5 por supuesto no
está incluido son todos los x menores
que menos
muy bien y esto es fácil de pensarlo no
si tiene que ser más chico que menos 5 y
más chico que 2 pues como menos 5 es más
chico que 2 deben ser solo esto es
verdad entonces si nosotros queremos
graficar al final
el conjunto de soluciones tenemos aquí
menos 5 y tenemos aquí el 2 y dijimos
que nuestras soluciones son estas todos
los que están a la derecha del 2 sin
incluir el 2 sin incluir el 2 y también
tenemos esta solución es verdad todos
los que están a la izquierda del -5 sin
incluir menos 5 entonces como te darás
cuenta no es tan complicado solo hay que
tener mucho cuidado vamos a ver un
último ejemplo digamos solo para para
practicar un poco tenemos menos x x 2 x
menos 14 debe ser mayor o igual que 24
muy bien entonces vamos a tratar de
resolver esto
llevándolo toda la forma estándar factor
izando y hacer
el mismo procedimiento que hicimos en el
ejercicio anterior entonces menos x x 2x
es menos 2x cuadrada y menos x x menos
14 son más 14 x y esto debe ser mayor o
igual que 24 muy bien ahora yo quiero
llevarlo a una forma estándar puede
empezar por dividir entre menos 2 de
ambos lados si división si divido entre
menos 2 de ambos lados que me queda me
queda x cuadrada menos 7 x y del lado
derecho me queda 24 entre menos 2 que es
menos 12 ahora yo dividía entre un
número negativo y ya sabemos que al
dividir entre un número negativo el
signo de la desigualdad se voltea y
entonces ahora tenemos un menor o igual
muy bien entonces si sumamos 12 de ambos
lados ya lo tenemos en nuestra forma
estándar digamos tenemos x cuadrada
menos 7x y sumamos 12 debe ser menor o
igual que 0 y aquí es en donde podemos
factorizar qué es lo que tendremos dos
números que multiplicados me den 12 y
que sumados me den menos 7 entonces por
ejemplo funcionan muy bien menos 3 y
menos 4 muy bien entonces esto es x
menos 3 por x menos 4 y esto debe ser
menor o igual que 0 muy bien fíjate que
menos 3 x menos 4 es 12 positivo y menos
3 menos 4 es menos 7 así que funciona
muy bien ahora aquí tenemos un caso
ligeramente distinto tenemos un producto
de dos números que es menor o igual que
0 esto esto qué quiere decir otra vez
pensemos piensa en dos números
cualesquiera que multiplicados me dan
algo menor o igual que 0 quiere decir
que uno era mayor o igual que 0 y el
otro era menor o igual que 0 ok entonces
puede pasar una de dos cosas
puede ser que x menos tres sea menor o
igual que cero pero para que esto sea
menor o igual que cero el otro tiene que
ser positivo
entonces x 4 es mayor o igual que 0 o
bien puede ser esto o puede pasar que el
primero sea el positivo x menos tres sea
mayor o igual que 0 y x menos 4 es menor
o igual que 0 muy bien entonces esto
esto en realidad es simplemente para que
el producto sea menor o igual que 0
verdad si tengo un producto de 2 números
que es negativo pues uno es positivo y
el otro es negativo muy bien y aquí
están estos dos casos ahora vamos a ver
qué ocurre en cada uno de ellos por
ejemplo en este caso verde
tendremos que x es menor o igual que 3 y
x es mayor o igual que 4 muy bien por
otro lado tendremos que x es mayor o
igual que 3 y x es menor o igual que 4
entonces tenemos estas dos posibilidades
estas dos posibilidades y las dos son
soluciones válidas excepto esta primera
fíjate qué
nos satisfacen que son más chicos que
tres y más grandes que cuatro pues en
este no hay posibilidad no hay
soluciones así que solo nos vamos a
quedar con esta solución verdad que son
todos los números que son más grandes o
iguales que tres y más chicos o iguales
que cuatro entonces nos tomamos el 3
este si es posible y nos tomamos todos
estos números que se encuentran entre 3
y 4 y el 4 también lo podemos incluir
muy bien entonces sé que esto pudo haber
sido confuso en realidad ya obtuvimos la
solución y quizás por eso es que lo
enseñan hasta las finales de la
secundaria o quizás en la preparatoria
solo es cosa de que recuerdes que el
producto de dos números es mayor o igual
que cero si tienen el mismo signo y que
el producto de dos números es menor o
igual que cero si tienen signos
contrarios
después la lógica solita se encarga de
decirte cómo resolver el problema muy
bien ahora es cosa de que resuelvas
algunos ejercicios que te diviertas